richtig dass ein thema was mich
emotionalisiert es ist das thema
inflation wir haben diese woche die
neuen zahlen bekommen 5,2 ist diese
inflationsrate im november gewesen
bedeutet einkaufen das leben an sich ist
in deutschland um 5,2 prozent teurer
geworden ein 29 jahres hoch wir haben es
aber auch nicht nur in deutschland
sondern in der ganzen euro-zone neben
byd mit sehr hohen inflationsraten zu
tun 4,9 prozent war der stand das
bedeutet auch in anderen ländern
schnellen die preise hoch hat viele
gründe
aber kern ist eigentlich dass es wenig
interesse gibt in der neuen
bundesregierung in der ampel regierung
etwas gegen diese inflation zu tun
schlimmer noch und das ist der eindruck
den ich habe das vor allem spd und grüne
eigentlich eher noch inflationstreiber
sein könnten und zwar mit ihrer
finanzpolitik zwar steht im
koalitionsvertrag ganz klar wenn man
will sich an die schuldenbremse halten
aber wenn man mal ins kleingedruckte
schaut er auch in die parteien rein hört
grüne und spd dann gibt es doch einen
massiven unmut darüber dass nicht zu
viele oder nicht mehr schulden gemacht
werden schulden wissen wir sind am ende
immer
inflationstreiber und auch wenn man sich
den koalitionsvertrag gut durchliest
dann wird man feststellen beispielsweise
co2 bepreisung häuser dämmung da kommen
ganz ganz viele zusätzliche kosten auf
die bürgerinnen und bürger zu 100 ende
und was würde christian wahrscheinlich
freuen profitiert der staat sogar noch
von inflation beispielsweise über die
mehrwertsteuer also meine these ist die
große koalition die warm jetzt gibt es
die ampelkoalition
beide profitieren von der inflation und
die ampel ist was das thema beendigung
der inflation angeht total verlogen ich
würde das thema noch höher ziehen weg
von der deutschen politik richtung
europäische zentralbank ich kann auch
viele ökonomen in deutschland nicht
verstehen die sagen das ist nur temporär
und einmaleffekte mit
mehrwertsteuersenkung nein das ding wird
länger dauern wir werden signifikant
mehr als zwei prozent im nächsten jahr
bestimmt drei prozent oder mehr im
durchschnitt haben ist meine feste
überzeugung die lieferengpässe bleiben
wir haben ein fachkräftemangel die
gefahr einer lohn-preis-spirale drohte
sehen wir jetzt schon in den vereinigten
staaten ja das könnte uns hier auch
drohen und ich muss ganz klar sagen ich
bin es satt rücksicht zu nehmen auf die
ezb nur weil es ein politisch
unabhängiges gremium ist nein auch ich
glaube ich bin in der pflicht die ezb
hat ein ganz klares mandat das heißt
geldwertstabilität und wenn wir
signifikant über zwei prozent liegen und
das machen die im moment und das ist
nicht kurzfristig dann muss reagieren
fordert ist die amerikanische notenbank
die wird jetzt angehen zumindest sagen
dass die meisten prognostiker denn das
was wir jetzt erleben das ist eine
enteignung mit kalter enteignung des
ganz normalen
bürgers der morgens auf seinen wecker
klopft und arbeiten geht dem wird geld
geklaut ich glaube wirklich erst hat
gesagt betrug am kleinen mann und das
ist es deswegen muss die ezb jetzt
handeln dazu gehört ja auch natürlich
sich ehrlich zu machen die amerikanische
notenbank haben sie angesprochen die hat
jetzt gesagt ich würde notenbankchef ich
würde das wort temporär bei dem begriff
inflation aus meinem vokabular streichen
hat also angedeutet es gibt eine
längerfristige inflation wäre schön wenn
jemand das hier auch in deutschland mal
zugeben würde und mit maßnahmen
entsprechend dagegen setzt mit dem wir
haben natürlich parallel immer noch die
nullzinsphase das heißt wenn man drei
vier prozent zinsen entsprechend nicht
hat aber dafür 34 prozent inflation
viele sagen ja wenn man diesen warenkorb
der ja zu inflations berechnung beiträgt
eben nicht nimmt sondern sich noch
andere güter nimmt dann sind wir schon
weit über zehn prozent inflation also
wenn man das nicht bekämpft dann bin ich
nehmen wir bei vier prozent innerhalb
von zehn jahren schon 40 prozent meines
geldes los und es trifft natürlich vor
allem gegen diejenigen auch besonders
die kein vermögen haben die nicht in der
lage sind sondern immer bei der nächsten
tank beim zapfen und beim einkauf 345
euro mehr bezahlen als beim letzten mal
aber ist das was wir sehen herr lienen
meinung da phrasiert einfach wieder als
angehörigen der partei von der die
bundeskanzlerin ja auch oder deren damit
die bundeskanzlerin auch es ist das am
ende nicht die quittung die wir bekommen
für die euro rettungspolitik wir wissen
warum die europäische zentralbank sich
ganz ganz schwer tut ihr
geld pumpen zu beenden und die zinsen zu
erhöhen weil sie sorge hat dass die
länder die sie gestützt hat mit zig und
arbeitssieg milliarden dass die dann
beispielsweise italien griechenland in
finanzielle schieflage geraten könnten
und wir die quali nächste euro krise
hätten also sehen wir die quittung
hierfür die euro rettungspolitik das ist
beispielsweise ein thema wo ich eine
andere meinung hatte als angela merkel
ich konnte diesen kurs nicht mittragen
eine währungsunion funktioniert nicht
wenn du keine durchgriffsrechte hass und
wenn du die durchgriffsrechte nicht hast
einen europäischen finanzminister wenn
wir nicht so weit sind und eine
politische union wollen sondern regeln
haben wir den maastrichter vertrag wo
sich keiner dran hält und gleichzeitig
ein regelsystem wo man sagt wenn du die
regeln einhält bekommst du weiter geld
wenn du die nicht einhält bekommen zu
trotzdem weiter geld dann bräuchte c't
du wie der sachverständigenrat ist
vorgeschlagen hat vor einigen jahren
einen austritt verfahren zu starten
beides findet die stadt ja gebe ich
ihnen völlig recht trotzdem ist jetzt
für mich die frage um das ist die
zentralste es gibt ein ganz klares
mandat das heißt geldwertstabilität es
gibt keine anderen ziele
und deswegen ist für mich jetzt ein
zentrale frage herr schäfer der wird
eigentlich nachfolger von jens weidmann
weil jens weidmann steht für stabilität
in deutschland und ich habe nicht mit
ihm gesprochen nach dem rücktritt ich
weiß nicht welche beweggründe hat man
denkt sich einiges gesagt aber die frage
ist ja dass sie waren ja eben top
informiert welche ihrer personalien die
sie da hatten für das
gesundheitsministerium vielleicht können
sie uns jetzt auch sagen wer nachfolger
von ihren zweiten garde spüre ich ein
bisschen spott dahinter ich habe meine
persönliche bei den persönlichen
favoriten genannt das war ulla schmidt
ob dies wird keine ahnung und andrea
nahles ist im gespräch tatsächlich für
verschiedene ministerien und ist
öffentlich genannt aber wir brauchen
jemand wieder na ja ich wäre nicht
ungewöhnlich wenn das jemand ist der
trotz aller unabhängigkeit ein gewisses
verhältnis zu dieser neuen
bundesregierung hat aber da der
finanzminister derjenige ist der
natürlich im engsten kontakt zur
bundesbank steht hofft man natürlich in
aller unabhängigkeit darauf dass da
dieser klare impetus von christian
lindner geldwertstabilität auch zu
pflegen auch sich da weiter fortsetzt
wobei am ende auch der
bundesbank-präsident das ist ja auch ein
grund für mehrere tritte die wir schon
gesehen haben axel weber als beispiel
der ja auch frustriert die brocken
hingeworfen hat richtig das ist der
dritte rücktritt den wir sehen im
eurosystem das hat eigentlich vorliegen
geben dass ein bundesbank präsident
schmeisst aber wir sehen es in diesem
eurosystem und warum weil wir
feststellen die geldpolitik wie sie
bisher die bundesbank gemacht hat hat
nichts mehr zu tun mit dem was die ezb
macht die deutsche sehr solide
geldpolitik die rent quasi an die pumpe
wenn es um die frage geht wie machen wir
weiter und das frustriert die deutschen
bundesbank präsidenten und wir sehen das
ergebnis schon wieder meist jemand gehen
und man kann nur hoffen dass ich nicht
mehr weg von den personalien und nochmal
zu dem großen thema inflation was ja
auch viele zuschauer und bürger
interessiert ist er immer einfach zu
kritisieren und ich hatte jan schäfer
jetzt den punkt gebracht aber auch ich
weiß selbst kritisieren ist immer
einfach ich habe auch vorschlägen
mitgebracht ja genau das ist was ganz
normalen bürger der pendelt ja der nie
in berlin sind u bahn hat und essbaren
der musste zwei euro jetzt knapp zahlen
sowie ihren lasten gehen wir haben ein
co2 preis das finde ich
volkswirtschaftlich richtig du musst die
fossilen energieträger teurer machen um
den druck zu erhöhen für die
alternativen aber du kannst jemanden auf
dem land nicht erzählen der kann jetzt
öpnv nutzen männern 23 mal umsteigt und
wir können das auch nicht innerhalb
eines jahres machen ich bin für den
ausbau von op en v aber die co2 abgabe
die gezahlt wir die geht ja in einen
topf das sind ja milliarden dieser topf
muss eins zu eins in der auszahlung
zurückgehen an diesen menschen und das
geht er nicht da gibt es über 50 prozent
sind irgendwelche programme subventionen
die da finanziert werden kann man alles
machen das muss man dann aber über
steuern machen sondern dieses geld muss
zurück ich habe das mal ausgerechnet
wenn man das machen würde hätte man im
jahr 2022 pro person ich würde auch eine
kopfpauschale nehmen es sind 170 180
euro dann hätte man auch in sozialen
effekt dass die unteren
einkommensgruppen mehr entlastet werden
als die oberen das hieße bei einer
vierköpfigen familie pro jahr 700 800
euro die eeg umlage muss dann auch noch
weg hätten wir über 1000 euro das wäre
für mich ein ganz konkreter entlastungs
punkte
zweiter vorschläge sagt vorschläge das
war einer das waren zwar immer die
eeg-umlage dass ich dann aber gerne mit
der stromsteuer weitermachen und vieles
mehr wenn wir aber wenn wir dann auch da
ernsthaft bei der eeg-umlage ist er
technisch die ökostromumlage jeder hat
muss die zahlen reden dann machen wir
hier linke tasche rechte tasche wir
lösen das problem nicht denn ob das
jetzt der verbraucher selbst bezahlt
oder am ende der steuerzahler weit aus
dem bundeshaushalt kommt das ist am ende
völlig egal wir müssen einfach
feststellen es gibt zwei kernprobleme
die wir haben wir haben den start als
preistreiber und wir haben eine ezb die
am ende auch nicht eingreifen des
staates nicht alleiniger preistreiber
scp die nicht eingreift die nicht
eingreifen kann weil sie sich selbst so
gefesselt hat in ihrer rettungspolitik
dass das gar nicht möglich ist
wesentlicher inflationstreiber ist auch
nicht nur der mangel an arbeitskräften
der wird auch dazu aber der mangel an
produkten halbleiterchips und
dergleichen die dazu führen dass waren
immer knapper werden das immer teurer
werden dadurch durch die knappheit und
da würde ich mir gerne wünschen ist auch
ein wirtschaftsminister jetzt mal sagt
dass man auf freunde wir sehen mal zu
dass das schnell abhilfe hat und das
wird dass dieses problem auf
internationaler ebene auch mal beenden
stimmt er an aber da haben wir uns eben
auch von staaten abhängig gemacht und
das sehenden auges gemacht die diese
abhängigkeit jetzt ausnutzen wenn ich
zum beispiel daran denke dass wir in
mecklenburg vorpommern dass frau
schwesig dort die sehr umstrittene
pipeline zu russland unbedingt fertig
bauen möchte und jetzt auch in betrieb
nehmen möchte so gibt man den russen die
uns alles andere als freundlich gesonnen
sind natürlich auch den hebel in die
hand hier das gab es mal ein bisschen
abzutreten und genau das machen die
russen jetzt ja auch insofern ist das
nicht nur eine frage des
wirtschaftsministeriums sondern auch
eine frage des außenministeriums und der
kanzlerin oder und auch des zukünftigen
kanzlers die sind ja sie sich ja alle
sehr einig was die frage von
gaslieferungen angeht und haben eine
entsprechende positionierung aber im
unterschied zu
chips mit gas ja nicht knapp sondern
wenn diese röhre tatsächlich irgendwann
eines tages mal angeschlossen werden
sollte dann strömt das gas hoffentlich
dadurch wir sind wären die russen nicht
abdrehen und das machen wir im letzten
vier jahrzehnte ja nicht gemacht wenn
sie befüllen ja diese erdgasspeicher
aber ich will jetzt hier nicht zum
plädoyer für diese pipeline werden auf
ein einziger dienste er immer noch dafür
aktiv ist aber trotzdem bms vergleichen
denn ist der mangel an chips und
dergleichen ein weitaus größerer als
dieser warum rufen sie sofort nach dem
start sind ich auch die firmen selber
geführt wenn sie mir helfen die die die
stehen also wir sagen jetzt auf als
staat in deutschland alles hochziehen
also wir haben eine kunststoff und 70%
abhängigkeit von china bei den chips
sind viele werke jetzt auch geschlossen
gegen korona klar also wie dem staat
sollen jetzt dass wieder alles
zurückholen und in deutschland aufbauen
es gibt ja da gibt es ja eine forderung
natürlich dass das wieder in
renationalisierung wird auch von großen
vertretern konservative bewegung wenn
wir mal nach amerika gucken und dann
etwas angucken dann war das natürlich
eine kernforderung diese dinge wieder
zurückziehen und auch in deutschland
gibt es natürlich entsprechende
bestrebung ich würde mir schon wünschen
dass ein verantwortlicher
wirtschaftsfachmann wirtschaftsminister
auch die entsprechend betroffenen
branchen zusammen rot und mit ihnen
gemeinsam erörtert was man tun kann um
diesen haltlosen zustande eben auch zu
verändern
zumindest könnte man von der politik
erwarten ich sehe das wie sie ich möchte
auch keine starken eingriffen des
staates in unserem wirtschaftsleben aber
dass man mal den ausverkauf an die
staaten die produkte ganz offensichtlich
auch in der wertschöpfungskette
behindern dass man diesen haus verkaufen
als stoppt das ist was was ich mir von
der neuen bundesregierung auf jeden fall
wünschen